what's going on guys this is Rob and
today on our vs. series we're going to
take a look at another battle that you
guys voted for know the symbiotes god
taking on spawn now as we do here we're
going to break down each of these
characters in terms of their origin and
powers and then declare a winner and
without further ado we'll get things
started by looking at null now Noel's
origin is a bit complicated right his
first full appearance was in venom
number 3 in 2018 and Donnie Cates and
Ryan Stegman are generally regarded as
the creators of no however it was later
revealed that null had actually appeared
five years earlier in for god of thunder
number six as an unnamed entity so for
that reason Jason Aaron and Butch juice
are oftentimes credited as co-creators
of null as well albeit he didn't really
seem to have a name at the time now as
for my opinion on the matter I think
that Donnie Cates is clearly the
creative force behind null and I highly
doubt that Jason Aaron had any idea that
he was creating null when he wrote Thor
number six so I consider Cates instead
Minh to be the creators of the semi @
God
but regardless null has been around
basically forever as in longer than the
universe has existed in Marvel Comics
and after the first firmament which is
basically the first Marvel universe to
exist null drifted to the abyss of
nothing before time itself started now
all that changes when the Celestials
begin creating the universe which wakes
him up and really pisses them off
because the darkness he enjoys has
basically been ruined by the light of
creation so literally no the Simeon God
got pissed off because the Sun came up
and woke him up out of his sleep that's
basically what it is more or less now to
get his revenge null forges a sword
known as the all black from the shadow
that he cast because of the presence of
light and uses it to cut the head off
one of the Celestials he's then banished
back into the void by the other
Celestials uses the decapitated head of
the celestial to temper his sword in its
cosmic energy and sets out to kill as
many gods as he can until he crashes on
an unnamed planet and is defeated by Gor
the god butcher who steals the all-black
sword from null and then he basically
enters a sleep-like state for an
extended period of time now after he
wakes up
Knowle accomplishes what we know him
best for once he figures now that he can
bond the living abyss that makes up his
armor with lesser beings he creates a
race of symbionts that he then uses as
an army to accomplish his goal of
exterminating the light of the universe
and killing and enslaving even more gods
now things ultimately go south for null
when two of his symbiote journey to
earth and one of them
Grindle encounters Thor who uses a blast
of lightning to separate null from most
of his symbionts now as a result many of
Noel's idiots bond to benevolent hosts
which corrupts the hive mind that they
all share and causes them to rebel
against and imprison all within their
home planet now this race would
eventually go on to be known as the
Clint heart and would be the race that
the venom Samia and other simius of the
Marvel Universe belong to now as you
probably know know was recently
reawakened and freed from this prison in
the aftermath of the absolute carnage
event and is once again working his way
through the universe conquering planets
as he heads to earth now as far as
powers go nulls are extremely vast -
given that he is an ancient deity and
has existed longer than the universe
itself now he's able to create and
control the dark energy that made up the
primordial darkness that was the abyss
that no inhabited before the creation of
the universe his mastery of this dark
energy appears to be basically endless
now as I mentioned earlier he was able
to harness it to create all black a
weapon capable of slaying a celestial
one of the most powerful cosmic entities
in the moral universe Noah was also able
to create an entire planet and race of
symbiotes from this energy and was able
to possess powerful cosmic beings and
deities using it Knowles able to
exercise complete dominion over his
creations even when their light-years
away and of course he's destroyed
countless planets and stars so we're
talking serious power levels when
discussing null now in addition to this
no possesses super-strength
haven't been able to kill several
deities and swing all black with enough
force to behead a celestial and
overpowering the Silver Surfer easily
although it should be noted that the
surfer was significantly weakened from
the way he normally is now the reason
that the surfer was basically weakened
was that he exhausted most of his power
cosmic in an attack on milk which did
injure him becuase no lasting damage nor
did psionic beams from ego the Living
Planet and so because of this along with
the fact that he survived the blast from
a celestial we know that Noel's
durability is at an absolutely insane
level but in the event that he is
injured he has an extremely efficient
regenerative healing factor that can
heal injuries that would be fatal not
only to any mortal but even cosmic
entities and other deities and so going
up against know we have spawn now spawn
was created by Todd McFarlane and first
appeared in a self-titled issue with
number one in 1992 now spawns the alter
ego of Al Simmons whose father was a
traveling salesman and whose mother was
an actual literal Satanist now as out
reaches adulthood
joins the Marine Corps followed by a
stint in the Secret Service and finally
the CIA now working as a CIA assassin
who begins to question the motivations
and methods employed by the agency and
is summarily killed by his partner at
the behest of one of their supporters
after he dies Alice sent to hell send
some of the people that he killed during
his career as a CIA assassin were
actually innocent
now once he's in hell al trades his soul
to a demon named mal Bhoja for the
opportunity to see his wife one more
time and in doing so becomes a hell
spawn a super-powered demonic entity
forced to do mal bogus bidding now
ultimately Simmons is sent back to earth
having lost most of his memories and
once he's on earth Spahn devotes his
time to using his powers to battle crime
in New York City pity him at odds with
the Mafia and other criminals before
moving on to more powerful opponents
including angels demons and gods now
spawn draws his powers from a symbiotic
suit known as the k7 letha that is made
up of a magical substance called necro
plasma that feeds off the energy emitted
by his body now the symbiote grants pawn
a variety of powers including superhuman
strength speed and durability as well as
allowing him to shape-shift and create
necrochasm shields and weapons and also
gives him an ESP like ability to warn
him of impending danger kind of like
Peter Parker spider sense not
technically speaking spawn does not have
a human body as he's also able to take
extreme amounts of damage and has
survived many injuries that would be
fatal to morals such as being
electrocuted impaled and dismembered now
he has even walked through the lava in
the fires of hell without being
permanently injured and it's been stated
that the only way to kill spawn is to
decapitate him with a weapon of heavenly
or magical origin now spawn is both
telekinetic and telepathic and is able
to use his telepathy to influence the
thoughts and behaviors of others as well
as create elaborate illusions he
possesses the powers of flight
teleportation and invisibility can phase
through solid objects and can even stop
time now one of his more interesting
abilities is that he can summon the
souls of all the people an individual
has ever harmed and allow them to rip
that individual apart now as we can see
spawn has a wide array of abilities that
can make him a formidable combatant and
even go toe-to-toe with some extremely
powerful beings now spawn is also able
to perform powerful feats of magic but
the amount that he can use this power
for is finite as each time he uses his
magic he depletes his magical reservoir
now this limitation of spawns power is
often depicted on panel with a counter
that lets the reader know how much
magical energy he has less
but this has admittedly been
inconsistently written and sometimes it
seems that that limitation is in place
while other times it does not seem to be
in place depending on what the storyline
calls for at the time so while this
magic is really only limited by his
imagination in terms of what he can do
with it he has to be careful and using
it because once it's depleted he can't
produce anymore of it but is he powerful
enough to take out no the god of the
symbiotes well before we answer that
question I want to address what some
people are likely going to point out is
one of spawns most impressive feats
desig jesse has the ability to warp
reality now fans of spawned probably
know that I'm referring to the instance
when spawn traps both God and Satan in a
pocket universe and basically wipes out
the entirety of heaven hell and earth
before remaking mankind now if we take
this feat at face value it suggests that
spawn is at or near omnipotence but this
comes with a couple of caveats first in
the spawn universe God and Satan are
merely deities and God is not the
progenitor or ruler of the universe like
the one above all in Marvel Comics in
fact while both beings are nearly
omnipotent neither of them are truly
omnipotent so it isn't like spawn trout
the most powerful being in his universe
in a pocket dimension the other caveat
is that when spawn did this he'd been
granted extra power by the mother who is
the actual creator of the universe and
therefore spawn was operating at a level
vastly above his normal power levels and
so as for who wins this battle if we
take spawn at his normal power level I
think no wins this match without much
difficulty while spawn is definitely no
slouch he is not a universal level
entity like Noah is and I would even go
as far as to say multi level no himself
is a God of order than the universe
itself and has slain entities far more
powerful and spawn and so I see this
playing out is spawned throwing
everything he has at null and depleting
all of his demonic magical reserves but
since null has a newer blast from a
celestial as well as the power cosmic
I don't think spawn is going to be able
to mortally wound him now no is going to
have a bit of a tough time defeating
spawn as I think spawn could defeat a
ton of symbionts but if we take into
account all black which has been capable
of beheading a celestial I don't see
spawn surviving a decapitating blow from
all black because even though it doesn't
technically come from heaven it is still
divine in origin having been created by
a god and that's how I see this battle
ultimately playing out given that we're
taking spawn as only having the
abilities he normally possesses now if
he was amped up by mother once a
he could probably defeat null by
trapping him in a pocket universe and
then leaving in there but that's not
really a fair fight since we'd be
basically giving him abilities that he
does not inherently possess as a hell
spawn so ultimately going pound for
pound in their normal States I'm gonna
give this victory to null so what happen
he said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end I want to say thank you
to all of you for being patrons I love
you guys be on the lookout for that poll
make sure you guys vote and I will catch
you all later
Bruce
[Music]